[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre sur
tv soixante dix huit pour ce premier
numéro de la saison du club de la presse
aujourd'hui sont avec nous alexandre
marqué bonjour journalistes responsables
notamment du secteur de saint-quentin
pour toutes les nouvelles et 7,8
actus.fr bonjour également à nouradine
agne bonjour nouradine bonjour monsieur
qui nous entend également journaliste à
marmite fm sur look 88.4 mais aussi
grégory canal et bonjour grégory jour le
rédacteur en chef adjoint de tv 78 et
nous avons un invité pour débuter ce
club de la presse othman mas rouge
bonjour bonjour premier vice-président
de la région ile-de-france membres du
mouvement libre fondée par valérie
pécresse
bienvenue sur ce plateau je vous propose
de découvrir ensemble le sommaire de ce
mois ci elle nous reviendrons sur les
annonces du président macron depuis les
murs hall 2 octobre dernier les grandes
lignes de la stratégie de la république
en acte était dévoilé un nouveau député
pour les yvelines philippe benassaya et
en mars prochain un nouveau passage aux
urnes pour les électeurs conseillers
départementaux conseillers régionaux
seront normalement à désigner si le
contexte sanitaire le permet dans le
reste de l'actualité nous reviendrons
également bien évidemment sur cette
crise de l'aco vide à 19 et vient en
dernière partie des missions les
personnalités biennoises du moins les
sujets prochainement à la une dans vos
médias locaux elle débute ont déjà avec
les dernières annonces du président
macron depuis les mureaux
[Musique]
cela quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes c'est un
projet conscient théorisé politico
religieux qui se concrétise par des
écarts répétés avec les valeurs de la
république qui se traduit souvent par la
constitution d'une contre société et
dont les manifestations sont la
déscolarisation des enfants le
développement de pratiques sportifs
culturels communautariser qui sont le
prétexte pour l'enseignement de principe
qui ne sont pas conformes aux lois de la
république et pour débuter cette
séquence vous l'avez entendu se dit cet
extrait du discours d' emmanuel macron
le 2 octobre dernier depuis les murs au
discours contre les séparatismes
plusieurs mesures annoncées on va
revenir sur quelques quelques unes tout
d'abord othman mastrou vous qui êtes élu
régional élu local aussi vous siéger
dans l'opposition à trappes depuis c'est
votre second mandat deuxième mandat
quand vous entendez les paroles du
président dès les premières minutes il a
pointé le séparatisme la notion de
l'islam radical
aussi vous vous dites qu enfin les vrais
problèmes sont abordés
ça faisait longtemps qu'on nous
annonçait une prise de parole du
président de la république sur sur ce
sujet et il est enfin sorti du silence
maintenant va falloir regarder les actes
et je constate aujourd'hui même
d'ailleurs que le mot de séparatisme ne
nie pas forcément retenue dans le texte
final de la loi c'est ce qu'annonce
ministre de l'intérieur il ya tout juste
quelques instants donc tout ça reste
extrêmement confus et j'espère qu'on
n'ait pas simplement dans une opération
de communication de récupération
politique
il y à un sujet c'est une réalité il y a
des gens une minorité une petite
minorité agissante qui a un projet
politique consiste à défier les lois de
la république on ne pas reconnaître ses
lois comme s'appliquant à l'ensemble de
notre population
il faut évidemment se donner les moyens
de lutter contre cela c'est une réalité
est malheureusement il ya encore des
territoires et puis surtout trop d'élus
qui joue avec ce type de sujet là qui
joue avec le clientélisme et qui laisse
prospérer cette minorité
quitte à rendre otage les autres
musulmans c'est à dire l'écrasante
majorité de ceux qui aspirent simplement
à vivre paisiblement donc il faut pas en
faire un sujet tabou il ya un vrai
suffit il y à des militants politiques
qui encore une fois considère que les
lois de la république ne doivent pas
s'appliquer que la loi religieuse est
supérieur ça ça n'est pas possible quand
on vit en société
dans un pays qui est un pays laïc
dans un pays dans lequel les lois de la
république doivent s'appliquer avant
tout et à tout le monde de la même
manière c'est vrai pour la laïcité c'est
vrai pour l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
et on peut le dire de manière très
apaisée très tranquille je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup de musulmans de france au
contraire qui se reconnaissent dans ce
que je viens de dire
et c'est à eux que je pense parce qu'ils
sont souvent pris encore une fois en
étau dans des débats qui deviennent très
caricaturaux le président de l'unc lui
qu'on a parlé aussi beaucoup de
sémantique dans ce discours a utilisé le
mot de séparatisme séparatisme
islamistes quand avant on parlait plutôt
de communautarisme est ce que le fait
d'utiliser ces mots d'après vous ça
change concrètement la donne je crois
que le débat sémantique il n'a pas
d'intérêt et la réalité ces dispositifs
derrière moi je comprends pas qu'on a
attendu trois ans pour faire enfin ce ce
discours on a perdu trois années je
prends un seul exemple nous on a
appliqué à la région de charte de la
laïcité qui s'applique à toutes les
associations qui bénéficient d'une
subvention régionale simplement pour
s'assurer qu'elles respectent les biens
des principes de la république et si
demain ou après demain on découvre que
dans un club sportif par exemple il n'ya
plus de sections féminines où il ya du
projet liquide nous il ya de la
radicalisation on peut demander le
remboursement de la subvention régionale
et je vois qu'aujourd'hui gouvernement
va enfin enfin et nous imiter faire à
une charge de ce type là pour les
subventions qui viennent de l'état à
l'interdît trois années donc moi
j'entends peut débattre de 2,2 du
séparatisme du communautarisme de la
radicalisation et c'est la seule réalité
derrière c'est comment on fait pour que
ce soit la république encore une fois
qu'ils sortent renforcées et partout sur
notre territoire sur ce type de sujet le
président quel cirque onu qui avait une
ghettoïsation qui avait été inquiété
lors la résultante de des années des
années de politique il a reconnu aussi
la part de responsabilité quelque part
de l'état et des différents
gouvernements dans la situation actuelle
affronter les problèmes de cette manière
là c'est aussi une bonne chose moi j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il fallait pas avoir
peur de nous mais les choses même si ça
ne plaît pas toujours été qu'un
lorsqu'on expliqué que justement on
avait une politique de peuplement sont
les mots du président justement d'avoir
regroupé les difficultés europe et les
communautés aussi et que ça ce sont des
erreurs qu'il faudra pas reproduire mais
les jambes vraiment envie d'une mixité
sociale une vraie mixité est partout moi
je suis élu d'une ville qui a compté
jusqu'à 78 % de logements sociaux les
gens veulent une vraie mixité sociale et
c'est pour ça qu encore une fois avec la
région l'a arrêté de financer du
logement très social la une a déjà plus
de 30 % ça fait déjà deux trois ans 80
points fait mais une fois qu'on a fait
cela ça ne suffit pas la réalité c'est
qu'il ya des élus locaux qui ont voulu
aussi installer cette situation qui ont
exploité ces problèmes moi je sors d'une
élection municipale pour la perdue a
très peu de voix et je pense que tu
rates mérité une vraie alternance parce
qu'on va traiter d'islamophobe dans un
montage vidéo anonyme qui a circulé à ça
une jours du premier tour il ya un
moment où la question des
responsabilités des élus qui font tout
pour se maintenir au pouvoir quitte à
jouer avec le feu sur ce type de sujet
elle doit être posée il faut aussi
comprendre que la politique de la ville
ça a été un échec alors aussi bien sur
les quelques années du mandat de
d'emmanuel macro mais aussi sur les
précédents mandats de gauche comme de
droite est ce qu'il ya eu un échec sur
la politique de la ville il y à un des
succès relatif est un échec relatif
pourquoi parce qu'on peut pas nier la
réalité de ce qui a changé aussi dans le
quotidien de la vie l'art je pense
davantage à une rénovation urbaine dont
moi je considère qu'elle était utile et
nécessaire mais c'est vrai qu'il y
beaucoup de saupoudrage dont beaucoup de
dispositifs différents qui n'ont pas
toujours produit leurs effets et que
l'émancipation sociale et économique
elle n'est pas arrivée
quand on regarde les indicateurs parus
en matière de formation professionnelle
on reste malheureusement sur des besoins
entre l'offre d'emploi et la demande
d'emploi qui ne sont pas alignés c'est
peut-être ce type de sujet avec des
entreprises par exemple que la politique
de la ville n'a pas su prendre en main
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui si on doit
avoir une action sur sur la politique de
la ville elle doit être davantage sur le
sujet économique et sur le fait qu'
effectivement les deux chacun a trouvé
le chemin de l'emploi
ce qui est possible ce qui est possible
ici à 50 ans livin on a plus d'emplois
que d'actifs et pourtant on a beaucoup
de demandeurs d'emploi dans un certain
nombre de quartiers prioritaires parce
que la politique de la ville ne s'est
pas intéressée à cette question du monde
de l'entreprise à cette question encore
une fois de la formation professionnelle
nouradine pour marmite où alexandre pour
pour les nouvelles est ce que parmi les
mesures qu'on était
annoncé par le président vous en avez
relevé quelques unes et peut-être ce
serait l'occasion de faire réagir othman
d'assaut sur le sujet moi je commence
alexandre je voulais poser la question
sur la confusion qui règne peut-être
autour de cette question de du
séparatisme et faire réagir
notre invité par exemple quand on
associe le séparatisme à l'apprentissage
de la langue arabe
voilà comment réagit notre notre notre
invité à ce sujet là puisqu'on le sait
ces sujets dérive rapidement on a
peut-être suivie même avant même
l'annoncé de et le discours du président
de la république
on est parti de thématiques qui semble
assez faible en tout cas en terme de
chiffre je pense au certificat de
virginité par exemple qui finalement sur
de longues interviews ont été mises en
avant et qui finalement relevé de 4 fin
pussycat dans tout l'hexagone
on a parlé récemment de polygamie est
également avec alain chabat
alors voilà on met un petit peu tout
dans cette dans cette réforme voilà
comment sortir peut-être de cette balade
saison big étude ces mélanges des genres
et est justement regarder les vraies
propositions qui sont capables de faire
avancer sur ce sujet nadine je crois que
vous avez raison à force de ne pas
vouloir traiter ce sujet ont fini par
mettre tous dans le même sac
et là vous parlez de la crainte de la
question de la langue arabe moi je
considère que c'est une langue qu'on
peut apprendre une langue étrangère
digne de ce nom mais qui doit aussi du
coup être valorisés en tant que tel et
pas forcément s'adresser uniquement à
des gens dont c'est l'origine parce
qu'il faut pas que ça soit pour le repli
identitaire c'est une vraie langue très
belle d'ailleurs pour ceux pour ceux qui
ont la chance de la pratiquer et qui qui
mérite d'être connue renseigner au même
titre que le mandarin au même titre que
d'autres langues et c'est vrai que ça
n'est pas tout à fait le même sujet moi
je le dis très clairement
mais de vrais sujets en réalité dont on
paie le prix aujourd'hui c'est ce ce
déni de la radicalisation c'est à dire
quand il ya un dévoiement de la pratique
religieuse au point d'être en rupture
avec le reste de la société
et encore une fois c'est le fait d'une
minorité mais d'une minorité qui nous
prend tous en otage et c'est vrai qu'une
fois que on n'a pas voulu reconnaître
cela pendant des années qu'on a laissé
ce sujet prospérer eh bien on se
retrouve à bord d'être question de
l'apprentissage de la langue arabe
donc je comprends l'idée qui consiste à
dire il faut pas enfermer les gens
uniquement dans leur culture d'origine
mais néanmoins c'est un sujet très
distant de la question de la
radicalisation et là dessus je ne peux
que vous rejoindre mais encore une fois
il faut regarder la réalité des actes et
c'est vrai que sur le terrain on a
laissé un peu trop ce qui était le
tenant d'une ligne dure du nine
rigoriste ceux qui ont mélangé pariant
politique et religion les ads et faire
ce qu'il voulait aujourd'hui on se
retrouve à mélanger des tas de sujets
qui n'ont rien à voir je considère quand
même que c'est mieux que le déni de la
réalité
au moins on peut débattre des vrais
sujets et que si on veut améliorer la
situation bien ma foi bien falloir
commencer par par rapport à quelques
quelques sujets et je note que ce n'est
pas le point principal l'intervention
d'un prévient david mesure effectivement
l'enseignement de l'arabe la
scolarisation obligatoire aussi à partir
de 2-3 ans interdit maintenant de
d'enseigner à domicile sauf pour des
motifs de santé fait partie des quelques
points qui ont été effectivement abordé
alexandre pour les nouvelles il veut
aussi financement des mosquées aussi je
crois que oui aussi et puis se voit et
skull mans aussi loi 1901 on peut
peut-être il revenir aussi la forme
associative peut-être sur ce point là
aussi faire évoluer en tout cas pousser
les associations cultuelles a évolué une
plus est sous la loi de 1901 et 1905
donc avec un meilleur contrôle
là aussi c'est important et il ya aussi
peut-être pour pour avancer un petit peu
dans la discussion il va falloir
travailler avec les élus de terrain très
concrètement pour mettre tout ça en
place
mais vous savez je suis l'élu qui a
expliqué pendant les années qu'il y
avait un sujet sur un certain nombre de
subventions de la ville de trappes à des
associations précisément parce que dans
la confusion la loi de 1901 la loi de
1905 que dans l'intérêt des associations
la fal et revoir le montage juridique y
était fragile et un certain nombre de
ces subventions d'ailleurs fini par être
retoqué par la préfecture et ça s'est
fait dans la douleur alors qu'il fallait
organiser les choses beaucoup plus
clairement dans mon jeu je suis
recueilli cette clarification whisky
religieux doit être dans le cadre de la
loi de 1905 skis associatif strictement
société doit être dans le cadre de la
loi de 1901 et le mélange des gens ne
doit pas exister il ne profite à
personne si ce n'est encore une fois
quelques élus qui sont peu scrupuleux on
me l'a reproché je constate
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde même le
président de la république a mis le du
temps avant d'arriver à 7 à cette idée
qui lui est suggéré par beaucoup et bien
fini par reconnaître que c'est dans la
clarté et dans un discours de vérité
qu'on peut enfin travailler tous
ensemble et comprennent des associations
dont beaucoup font un vrai travail et ne
sont absolument pas en cause ne sont pas
dans l dans le séparatisme mais elles
ont été amalgamés avec 7
ils sont dans le séparatisme parce qu'on
était dans un espèce de flou juridique
et dans deux formes juridiques étaient
contradictoires et qui se superposent et
travailler tous ensemble c'est plus ou
moins le message qui a été véhiculé
aussi par nadia et hier qui était votre
invité au moment où nous faisons cette
émission c'était hier dans votre journal
grégory on va écouter un des extraits
elle parle du travail et de la cohésion
nécessaire autour de ce sujet ce dont
nous avons besoin c'est effectivement de
travailler avec les élus avec les
acteurs pour avancer sur un sujet qui
mérite notre adhésion et qui mérite
aussi de travailler ensemble
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui se diviser
sur un sujet aussi grave et au et qui
impacte encore une fois la vie des
habitants et notamment dans les
quartiers politique de la vie les
victimes de séparatistes ou des thèses
séparatistes
si aussi les habitants des quartiers et
il est de notre rôle de notre devoir de
veiller à leur protection
travailler tous ensemble comment
concrètement l'état avec ce nouveau plan
qui va être mis en place la région les
élus de terrain véritablement locaux au
sein des municipalités vont pouvoir
travailler ensemble jo jo reyes et au
dialogue
il existe ce dialogue déjà oui il existe
ce dialogue notamment avec concrètement
enfin avec des mesures concrètes et au
delà des réunions et des groupes de
travail n'ont pas de regarder en avant
les yvelines vous parle de ce que je
connais il y a un vrai un vrai dialogue
permanent il est très attentif un
certain nombre de situations et on
travaille très bien
région département collectivités et état
dans leurs prêts à travers pardon les
autorités préfectorales
mais encore faut-il parler le même
langage pour pouvoir travailler ensemble
et je constate d'ailleurs
j'entends la ministre de la ville nadia
est sa première fois que je l'entends
parler de séparatisme l'a tout de suite
sur votre plateau alors quel que soit le
nom qu'on utilise donc je constate qu'il
ya une évolution puisque pendant des
années à sa faim nombre d'élus nous ont
expliqué qu'il n'y avait aucun sujet et
que c'était stigmatiser les territoires
que de dire qu'il ya des enjeux qui ne
sont pas traités donc je constate
qu'elle même évolué sur ce sujet là donc
c'est bien on va pouvoir travailler
ensemble moi c'est tout ce que c'est
tout ce que je demande et encore une
fois nous en tout cas je prends ma
casquette de région ont fait le
nécessaire
on la firme n'a cessé de on n'a pas
arrêté de le faire et encore une fois
mais il faut qu'on fasse on est de même
langage le même logiciel de reconnaître
qu'il ya des sujets de séparatisme ou de
repli identitaire peu importe tout cas
mais le sujet d'insécurité encore sur un
certain nombre de territoires j'aimerais
que la ministre de la ville sont saisis
ce n'est pas contradictoire de parler
aussi de sécurité
dans les quartiers populaires en même
temps qu'on parle de formation d'emploi
ou des social c'est un tout et on l'a
trop délaissé les sujets régaliens parce
qu'on avait peur est bien de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu malheureusement le
feu il est là aujourd'hui il faut bien
le cres été intelligemment
nous allons continuer la discussion avec
vous à moins que les autres journalistes
fait intervenir à vous poser une
dernière question sur le sujet et
avancez un peu dans les différents
rapidement pour m'indigner hawkman nas
ou comment vous allez puisque vous
disais qu'à la l'instant qu'il y avait
le feu que le feu était assez intense
même quelle mesure si vous pouviez ont
cité une va pour vous concrètement
permettre de lutter contre ce phénomène
d'ampleur ce que je veux bien quand on
parle de la scolarisation à partir de 3
ans la charte de la laïcité
bon je suppose que les plus radicaux
quand ils entendent parler de faire de
la laïcité ou d'autre chose ça les fait
ça leur fait très peur si l'on est assez
ironique bien sûr donc qu'est-ce que
voilà qu'elle concrètement qu'est ce qui
va faire que il va y avoir un changement
parce que là ça ressemble plus à des
mesures dont certaines sont déjà prises
vous l'avez dit par là par la région
pour la charte de la laïcité mais sur le
fond qu'est ce qui va faire changer les
choses
alors dans ce que vous avez entendu du
discours de d'emmanuel macro alors tout
d'abord vous avez dit vous même on se
dira tout ce qui est le feu
effectivement je veux dire quand je dis
qu'est le feu ça veut aussi dire qui est
une partie de la population qui
chi chi chi chi chi en décalage l'une
par rapport à l'autre si vous voulez et
on voir et attrape le front national
rassemblant sonel fait d'excellents
scores attrape en réalité c'est parce
que il ya aussi une partie de la
population qui a l'impression que c'est
un sujet qui n'est pas traitée est en
train de monter les gens les uns
faisaient donc il ya le feu passé le feu
de la cohésion du manque de cohésion
dans notre pays qui moi me fait froid
dans le dos d'avoir des gens qui ne se
parlent plus qu'ils ne se reconnaissent
plus qu'ils ne reconnaissent plus entre
les mêmes règles de vie commune donc oui
il ya le feu mais une fois qu'on a dit
cela c'est comment on fait pour que les
gens puissent à nouveau vivre comme une
seule société et donc oui ça suppose que
des règles s'appliquent il faut pas
avoir peur aussi d'un discours de
fermeté mais quand on parle de la charte
de la laïcité ce n'est pas anecdotique
je tiens à le dire s'est passablement
une charte déclarative
c'est à dire qu'on sait nous donne un
fondement juridique aller récupérer
l'argent public quand les associations
les structures en question ne respectent
pas les règles de la république s'est
lavée mis en place au sein de la région
ça tout à fait donc ce n'est pas une
charte
un voeu pieux je dis ça parce que la
ville de trappes a fini aussi à mad man
la mettre en place une charte mais qui
ne suffit pas des faits il n'y a pas de
comité de suivi il n'y a pas de mesures
concrètes et pas de contrôle bon
évidemment si c'est pour faire une
charte de principes ça ne sert à rien
mais donc vous voyez que au delà des
mots il ya le détail opérationnelle
toujours et c'est pour ça que
j'interroge la volonté politique du
président de la république a mis trois 3
ans prend la parole j'espère que
derrière une vraie volonté d'aller au
bout de ce sujet et de encore une fois
de s'attaquer non pas aux musulmans qui
encore une fois dans leur écrasante
majorité aspirent à vivre paisiblement
vers cette petite minorité qui nous
coûte cher et qui lui en réalité nous
pourrit la vie
je le dis comme je le pense et en
voulant sortir du cadre de nos règles
communes
il ya d'autres mesures que je pourrais
vous citer quand on parle de la
ghettoïsation c'est vrai que c'est un
vrai sujet et que on n'est pas assez
nombreux encore aujourd'hui vous voyez
ça ce n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde
on a eu ce sujet précemment accord à la
verrière où il y avait une volonté
d'augmenter encore le nombre de
logements sociaux à la verrière avec le
projet de la zac de bécane pour parler
local et donc il ya on n'a pas encore
tous le même logiciel
et c'est pour cela que faut qu'on
continue à débattre mais je crois que
l'opinion publique aujourd'hui c'est
faire un avis et moi je me réjouis quand
tout cas ya une prise de conscience
mais c'est sûr que le projet le problème
ne va pas être réglée avec une seule
mesure
me rate ça c'est certain et on aura
l'occasion bien évidemment de suivre ce
sujet d'en parler régulièrement sur
notre antenne et dans vos différents
médias locaux passons au reste de
l'actualité à présent avant de parler de
la législative partielle il ya un
nouveau député dans les yvelines avant
de parler aussi des régionales avec vous
autres magnats through l'élection
normalement devrait se dérouler en mars
prochain parlant de la situation qu'au
vide 19 après un été de léger répit la
situation se dégrade à nouveau il faut
non seulement vivre avec mais aussi
vivre avec cette crainte pourquoi pas
d'un potentiel reconfirme ans je
voudrais que nous et couture tout
d'abord ces quelques yvelinois qui
témoigne un petit peu leur situation au
quotidien
je vis ça sans trop de peur malgré que
je travaille dans des structures
d'enseignement où effectivement on est
très vite ramenés à se retrouver en
confinement dans cette période
voilà pour la protection du tout ce jeu
dhabi a si mal comme tout le monde à mon
avis quoi ont renseigné on est sûr
renseigner sur à four mais on ne s'est
pas fondamentalement ce qui est le vrai
du faux toujours là dedans et ben on
protège parce qu'on a des réflexes
citoyens en fait j'essaie de m'habituer
à porter un masque
toute la journée dans mon travail où
l'on fait du télétravail et puis on
s'adapte un vraiment mal masque ça c'est
ce n'est pas le plus jeune je préfère
porter un masque est debout plutôt que
d'être couché en réanimation
moi je travaille conservateur musique à
côté c'est assez compliqué les
restrictions en tant que musicienne
professionnelle on peut plus jouer on a
pu te concerne pour le monde de la
culture c'est très très compliqué et je
sais le problème c'est qu'on rencontre
plus grand monde quoi pour le futur
j'espère que ça va s'arranger
c'est surtout ça vivre avec vivre avec
cette maladie avec cette crainte
également sur le terrain alexandre pour
7,8 actu et les nouvelles vous avez le
sentiment que les yvelinois vivent avec
hook et commence à y avoir aussi
quelques fois un peu un ras-le-bol et
puis des inquiétudes plus ou moins
justifiées tout de même oui c'est simple
c'est un peu flou et on voit que les
illinois apprennent à vivre avec mais
c'est pas toujours très très clairs quoi
il ya par exemple
on voit entre les centres de dépistage
ou caméra tu attrapes où ça se passe
bien ou où les délais sont assez courts
où les résultats sont obtenus dans les
24 heures et celui de mantes la jolie
par exemple les délais sont beaucoup
plus longs on voit que tout ça n'est pas
un peu flou donc on va jamais jamais une
amie par exemple que qu'était la vie d'à
côté de mantes la jolie à l'aigle
jusqu'à trappe
pour ce faire pour se faire dépister
alors quand à côté cheveux mais parce
que vous voyez donc c'est quand même pas
très évident pour parler des autres
domaines
dans les sports on voit que les
championnats par exemple handball ou
envolées ou en basket à peine repris ils
sont déjà arrêtés parce que ça paraît
compliqué de se déplacer dans les
yvelines ont peu joué mais par exemple
on peut pas jouer dans la petite
couronne de paris
sans parler du social ou là les plans
sociaux se multiplient c'est quand même
c'est quand même une rentrée compliquée
qu'on a tous les niveaux sont très
compliquées et justement autres menaces
qu en tant qu'élu local élu à la région
aussi il ya beaucoup de problématiques
alors on va pas faire un inventaire et
pouvoir tout dressé mais mais mais
concrètement tout de même comme en
essais n'ont pas de rassurer mais dd
parce que je pense aux entreprises déjà
on voit un début de deux vagues de
licenciements de plans sociaux sur
différentes entreprises et ça concerne à
la fois des entreprises de saint quentin
en yvelines d'ailleurs que des
entreprises au sein de la région donc
déjà règne sur ce secteur là ne
serait-ce que la région vous n'allez pas
pouvoir aider toutes les entreprises de
manière indéterminée et puis a contrario
aussi peut être contrôlé les plans
sociaux qui sont mis en place pour pas
utiliser non plus là la justification de
la crise qu vide pour fermer des
entreprises ou les délocaliser moi j'ai
beaucoup de reproches à faire à l'état
et au gouvernement de la manière dont
cette crise a été gérée mais pour autant
je considère que notre rôle c'est de
travailler main dans la main et qui en
sortent d'essayer de trouver la
meilleure manière d'accompagner tous
ceux qui souffrent de cette crise c'est
pour ça que je ne nierai pas au delà des
critiques que j'ai fait mais c'est vrai
que des choses qui m'ont beaucoup étonné
on a vu un instant sur les tests ça a
été très compliqué on pourrait parler
également des masques au tout début de
la crise sur le sujet économique puisque
c'est le sens de votre question nous
notre rôle a été de se dire bon l'état a
mis en place un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui vont tout à fait dans le
bon sens sur le chômage partiel sur les
prêts garantis que nous gardons qu'ils
sont
hier avec l'état nous allons essayer
d'aller là où il ya des trous dans la
raquette pour ça que nous avons mis en
place le fonds résilience par exemple
avec 70 intercommunalités
d'ile-de-france et qu'elles ont toutes
cosigné avec nous dans le cadre de ce
fonds pour précisément financer toutes
les structures qui n'ont pas pu
bénéficier des prêts garantis par l'état
le but est de ne laisser personne au
bord du chemin ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'y aura pas de casse sociale ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'y aura pas de casse
économique en suit de très près les
chiffres du chômage et c'est vrai que
c'est inquiétant et que on va avoir des
mois forcément difficile on va essayer
d'atténuer au maximum les effets de
cette crise encore une fois par des
aides ciblées
hélas la situation de tout secteur
événementiel du secteur touristique qui
fait vivre énormément de monde en ile de
france plus de 500 mille emplois directs
et indirects dans le secteur du tourisme
les restaurateurs les hôteliers les bars
les cafetiers c'est vrai que c'est un
énorme sujet c'est pour cela qu'on suit
aussi de très près ce qui va être dit là
dans l'immédiat puisque là aussi on a
une grande confusion sur qui peut ouvrir
et dans quelles conditions il va falloir
là aussi qu'on continue à être vigilants
nous région on demanda au gouvernement
ce qu'on ne peut pas faire nous mêmes
sur un certain nombre de choses par
exemple sur le chômage
pour tous ceux qui ont des métiers
précaire et qui ne vont plus pouvoir
travailler c'est particulièrement le cas
dans les secteurs que j'ai cités il faut
qu'on puisse neutraliser les périodes de
chômage pour que ce ne soit pas
décomptés dans leur allocation actuelle
parce qu'on sait que c'est une période
exceptionnelle et qui veut peut
malheureusement être amenée à durer
encore quelques mois et donc voilà c'est
un travail de tous les instants la
vénération de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
joue son rôle aussi dans le cas du fonds
résilience dont j'ai parlé on ya fléchi
500000 euros et ainsi de suite pour que
l'on ne laisse personne au bord du
chemin et malheureusement je crois qu'on
va être amenée à continuer cet effort
financier conséquent dans la durée il va
nous rester moins d'une dizaine de
minutes pour profiter de votre présence
et gmac on parle tout de même de
politique
vous n'êtes pas le sans le savoir même
si la participation était faible il ya
un nouveau député dans la 11e
circonscription vous en est le suppléant
c'est philippe benassaya c'est une
reconquête de droite déjà qu'une fois de
plus pour les autres journalistes
n'hésitez pas à me faire signe pour
intervenir
je pense que les électeurs pour ceux qui
se sont déplacés parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'abstention dans
une élection partielle dans un contexte
sanitaire compliqué mais en tout cas
ceux qui sont déplacés à vos envies de
clarté on l'a retrouvé quelque chose
d'assez claire finalement entre
polarisation droite gauche assez assez
clair et je crois que voter pour en
marche à cette élection on ne savait pas
ce que ça voulait dire de quoi c'était
le nom il ya des lignes qui cohabitent
république on remarque qu'il ya des gens
que je respecte
y compris sur le sujet de la république
par exemple et dans lesquels je retrouve
des choses en commun mais on a d'autres
dont je ne comprends pas du tout les
options politiques et donc ils ont
choisi la clarté moi je me réjouis parce
qu'ils ont choisi d'élire philippe
benassaya qui est amer qui est ancré sur
le territoire qui connaît bien ces deux
circonscriptions avec lequel j'ai choisi
de faire équipe au titre du
rassemblement pour qu'on soit tous unis
et je suis content que ça ait payé je
n'aurais pas voulu que ce soit madame
grands groupes qui nous représente à
l'assemblée nationale avec laquelle j'ai
énormément de différences y compris les
rassurer maire-adjointe à trapani radio
attentes rattrape en charge du scolaire
et chacun pourra juger si le travail est
fait ou non attrapé en matière de
scolaires et je considérais d'ailleurs
qu'elle avait certainement mieux à faire
dans le cas de cette rentrée que de
vouloir partir à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai parlé avec el nil divergences on
parlait à l'instant de séparatisme et de
laïcité
madame brand group n'a pas voté la
charte de la laïcité dont je vous parle
dans la région elle n'a pas voulu la
beauté sexy en tant qu'élu régionales de
mai les sous titres à chaque fois qu'on
les suive
on a besoin de clarté à la fois
effectivement sur qui fait quoi et puis
sur ce que chacun défend réellement au
delà des paroles et des valeurs et de ce
qu'on écrit sur les tracts mais dans la
réalité des actes alors après les voilà
pour vous répondre bien évidemment je
passe la parole alexandre qui me l'avait
demandé nouradine et puis juste après ce
sera pour vous alexandre whitman
pensez vous que philippe benassaya aura
le temps mais des actions en un an et
demi mandat et en étant dans
l'opposition au palais bourbon le rôle
d'un député n'est pas de mener des
actions puissent pas élu local il est
par la tête d'un exécutif local il l'a
été il a fait du très bon travail dans
sa ville et je crois que c'est aussi ça
qui a été plébiscité à bois d'arcy
notamment et sur rien sur son fronton
la réalité c'est qu'il est là pour
défendre des valeurs et je pense qu'un
député d'opposition de plus dans le
principal groupe d'opposition
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale
c'est plutôt une bonne chose pour tous
ceux en tout cas qui pensent qu' il ya
des choses à dire à ce gouvernement il
ya des choses à infléchir il ya des
amendements à apporter à la politique
nationale
on y arrive qu'on n'y arrive pas je
pense qu'effectivement un siège de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle était plutôt une
bonne chose même si évidemment c'est
pour 18 mois même si évidemment il
n'aura pas la capacité d'agir dit
directement mais je crois qu'en tout cas
les deux candidats qu'ils sont arrivés
le second tour était tous les deux
d'opposition et encore une fois je crois
que cette opposition là et au moins
clair sur ses valeurs par rapport à
celle que je critiquais l'instant sa
traditionnelle que je voulais et
effectivement c'est vrai c'est le retour
d'après vous devez de ce schéma
traditionnel gauche-droite
aujourd'hui c'est le cas mais encore une
fois moi je trouve qu'on a besoin de
clarté et moi j'ai jamais caché mes
valeurs j'ai toujours porté sa pas
toujours été simple équipement je suis
allé d'une ville on n'a jamais été
majoritaire même si on arrive maintenant
à y faire des scores conséquent mais la
réalité c'est que les gens nous juger
sur nos actes et dans têtu sur la
cohérence et c'est pas simplement de
savoir si c'est la droite ou la gauche
c'est de savoir est-ce qu'on ait une
cohérence sur les valeurs qu'on veut
porter et je crois qu'ils grande attente
aujourd'hui par rapport aux valeurs de
la droite dans notre pays'' et nouradine
oui rapidement parce que c'est une
question qui est souvent balayé un petit
peu d'un revers de la main par les
politiques cette question de
l'abstention
à partir de combien de pourcentage
d'abstention on va considérer dans notre
pays qu'une que l'élection est
illégitime
là on en est à sur l'abstention 450 581
4 % sur ce score de 90 à trappes et 90
autres appris et 90 attrape alors même
que tout a été fait pour mobiliser en
faveur effectivement de l'équipe
municipale avec madame grand nombre est
encore une fois
moi j'ai fait partie de tous ceux de
ceux qui ont toujours dit qu'ils avaient
un énorme sujet d'abstention lépi trap
est effectivement une ville où il ya
plus d'abstention encore que dans le cas
de la circonscription c'est dramatique
je vous mettre à l'aise noureddine moi
je suis favorable à la reconnaissance du
vote blanc
et pourquoi pas d'ailleurs à ce qu'ils
effectuent en y annexant puisse être
joué une fois anta diop sont sont trop
fortes
après il le mettait pas causer de
l'instabilité donc à un moment il ya une
élection faut bien choisir et une
obligation de voter
en tout cas il faut responsabiliser les
électeurs parce que qu'on le veuille ou
pas il y avait un député a désigné la et
tous ceux qui ne se reconnaissent pas
aurait pu se présenter d'ailleurs il n'y
avait pas besoin ni de sanction d'un
parti suffisait d'être demain donc
c'était assez simple à faire donc c'est
pas tout dit de regretter reste on s'en
faut aussi dire à tous les électeurs
qu'au bout d'un moment quand on n'est
pas content de la vie politique
eh bien on s'engage et moi même ça fait
comment dire les choisi de m'engager à
un moment où c'était pas évident je vais
jamais fait de politique avant j'ai
choisi de m'engager
il faut aussi s'engager voilà mais c'est
vrai qu'on est un sujet qui est massif
et que j'ai l'impression que désormais
pour tricher dans une élection de boer
plus les irun mai
les vides et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
le sentiment que j'ai parce que ça
blesse forcément une élection forcément
et on va voir s'il y aura de la
participation au prochain scrutin le
prochain scrutin normalement ce sera il
sera double à la fois élections
départementales ancien cantonales faudra
voter pour les élus dans les différents
départements notamment les yvelines et
puis à la région aussi région
ile-de-france alors je rappelle que vous
êtes premier vice président de la région
ile de france que vous faites partie du
mouvement libre de valérie pécresse un
peu à la marge des républicains
finalement est-ce que vous êtes déjà en
campagne très clairement aux abords qui
sera éventuellement en mars les date
sera confirmée mais d'abord on n'est pas
à la marge une grande famille politique
et des sensibilités des nuances
j'apprécie fait en fermant d'entre eux
cela qu'on lui la ligne des républicains
et la ligne libre même si on le voit
dans les scrutins aujourd'hui vous vous
rassemblez oui grèce a annoncé qu'elle
quitte seulement le party les
républicains
oui parce qu'il ya un moment où la ligne
ne correspondait pas à ce qu'on voulait
porter en tout cas moi je me suis pas
reconnu sur une certain nombre d'options
à un certain moment donné au sein des
républicains et donc on le dit il faut
aussi que le débat interne vivent ils
ces avoirs des sensibilités différentes
la réalité c'est qu'on passe très
rassemblé on le voit dans les villes
congères on le voit dans les rangs la
vue à l'occasion de cette élection
partielle qu'un seul candidat de la
droite et du centre
d'ailleurs je tiens à le dire avec le
soutien de l'ue dit et c'est en fait que
vous aviez annoncé votre candidature
malheureuse et on attend que les
tremblements
tout à fait je vais finalement vous êtes
rassemblés oui et c'est ma vision c'est
le cinquième temps pour le débat et puis
un temps ensuite où il faut que chacun
en responsabilité prenne une décision si
on était partie divisée
ça aurait été totalement irresponsable
de ma part et donc j'ai choisi une
responsabilité de me retirer
voilà et puis vous avez vous l'avais dit
je suis premier vice président de la
région et notre sujet aujourd'hui c est
ce qu on veut continuer avec une région
qui s'est beaucoup modernisé qui a
beaucoup réduit son train de vie qu'il
choisit d'investir beaucoup plus qu'elle
ne finance son propre train de vie et
jamais la région n'a autant investi sur
les transports sur les lycées sur
développement économique
et je crois que ce travail qui a été
fait depuis cinq ans est colossal et je
ne veux pas d'un retour en arrière mais
vous m'avez parlé d' abstention et c'est
pour ça que vous l'avez vu nous on a
commencé d'ores et déjà à parler du fond
on fasse un certain nombre de réunions
publiques dans les dents les dans les
départements j'en ai fait moi l'occasion
de la moitié notre mandat pour venir
rendre des comptes dans les faits 25
partout en ile de france et donc on va
continuer à faire ce travail là
et j'espère qu'un maximum de gens qui
vont venir ne serait ce que poser leurs
questions nous accompagnent dans les
rangs quand on est élu l'otan paille
permanente à internet parce qu'on n'est
pas dépositaires de notre mandat on est
de passage et qu'il faut rendre des
comptes mais vous aimeriez bien avoir un
nouveau mandat à deux mois je veux pas
d'écouter avant des dates sur ce valérie
pécresse et avec porté également par
vous sur le terrain de l'aek reste on
verra c'est les candidates parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une crise qui fait
que matin midi et soir
il faut qu'elle soit vigilante sur ce
qui se passe mais la réalité c'est qu'il
n'est pas question pour nous est
effectivement quelques la région renoue
avec tous les travers qu'elle a connues
pendant 17 années de gauche oui selon
les différents sondages en tout cas les
premiers qui sont sortis ce serait un
duel entre valérie pécresse et un
certain jean michel blanquer herminis de
l'éducation qui avait parait vraiment
caché sa volonté d'être éventuellement
candidat pour la région et le dernier
sondage ifop et donner tous les deux en
tête on devait la wii même on était
assez de vent en tête parce que je lis
je pense que l'alternance qui a eu lieu
en 2015 qui a beaucoup d'électeurs qui
ont envie de la conforter mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'on ait un nouveau
projet ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
explique tout ce qu'on a fait pendant
cinq ans et encore une fois
moi j'espère que cette campagne qui va
pas démarrer tout de suite mais sera en
tout cas sur le fond mais pas sur les
histoires de personnes et pas sur les
attaques continuent la ceinture comme
juste en inciter les franciliens aller
voter on ne sait pas s'il y aura aussi
une forte abstention de leur dire voilà
le fait de mettre ce bulletin dans
l'urne ça peut influer sur des sujets la
région on parle des lycées on parle des
transports il ya quand même des sujets
d'importance comment les inciter les
français à aller voter
je voulais dit en fait il faut pas leur
parler du vote il faut leur parler de ce
qu'ils veulent pour leurs territoires de
leurs lignes de transport pourquoi elle
est comme elle est aujourd'hui combien
de rames rénovées parmi les 700 grammes
sont arrivés c est tout cela on est à
leur disposition et c'est pour ça qu'on
se déplace partout sur le territoire
on sera à poissy ici dans les yvelines
on va continuer à le faire que les gens
viennent et ne viennent pas simplement
se disant il ya une élection nous
demande de venir moi j'ai commencé cette
série de réunions dès 2010 n ous avez
trois ans que je sillonne ile-de-france
pour rendre des comptes
simplement qu'on vienne nous interpeller
les gens ont le droit de nous demander
des comptes et nous demander ce qu'on
fait concrètement pour leur transport
pour leur lycée pour leur sécurité
aussi l'afrique sont d'accord ils sont
pas d'accord ils votent en leur âme et
conscience
mais s'il n'y a pas ce débat s'il ya pas
cet intérêt pour les questions de fond
eh bien j'ai peur que malheureusement
que l'abstention continue de progresser
nous on fera notre parle du travail
alexandre nouradine une dernière
question à notre invité peut-être oui
un an après les régionales
les présidentielles est-ce que vous
verriez bien valérie pécresse candidate
à la présidentielle
je pensais que vous allez lui demander à
un coin de 9 trous alexandre est ce que
vous arrivez vous arrivez présidentielle
pour vous dire les choses très
franchement vous y présenter une période
politique tel nom mais si vous voulez en
personne n'a de visibilité sur rien
forcément
mais la question se pose absolument par
une crise sanitaire majeure sais même
pas si les régionales vont avoir lieu
dans six mois
est-ce que valérie pécresse a une place
importante au sein de l'échiquier
politique évidemment oui est-ce qu'il a
une place majeure au sein de la droite
et du sens de la droite républicaine ce
que moi j'aime bien appelé la droite
républicaine
la réponse est oui parce que il y aura
une candidature à la présidentielle en
2020 dont on ne sait même pas
aujourd'hui si le président sortant
pourra se représenter qu'elle sera
l'échiquier politique il ya des
régionales et départementales très très
franchement c'est pas de la langue de
bois mais on se fait plaisir si vous
voulez le vrai sujet d'abord encore une
fois pour nous c'est vrai que ça va
payer régionales parce qu'il n'est pas
question que le travail qui a été fait
jusque là et bien sûr bazarder par ceux
là même qui ont planté la région pendant
très longtemps on aurait pas votre
réponse alexandre mais pourrait avoir
comment dire représenter cette
candidature de la droite et du centre
ont parlé tout à l'heure de la situation
chez les républicains au delà même des
partis de l'union de cette droite et du
centre bansky fondamental c'est que cet
espace politique ne disparaissent pas
moi je ne veux pas d'un duel emmanuel
macron marine le pen en 2022 et j'irai
dans le sens évidemment de tout ce qui
fera que ce duel puis s'être cassé si
valérie pécresse peut jouer un rôle là
dessus j'en serais ravi généralement de
qualité pour ça est-ce qu'elle le voudra
s qu'elle le pourra à ce que les
circonstances ils prêteront est-ce que
cet espace politique
j'espère qu'il continuera à exister
d'ici là à ce que ce sera le cas je vous
donne rendez vous plutôt vers 2022 on y
sera on va déjà effectivement laissé
passer la situation actuelle merci
beaucoup aux doigts d'être venu
participent à ce club de la presse merci
à vous et nous poursuivons cette édition
à présent
[Musique]
quelles sont les personnalités des
yvelines de ce mois ci celles qui ont
marqué l'actualité du département ces
dernières semaines chacun des
journalistes des médias locaux va se
prononcer et on va commencer avec vous
nous radine wilfried j'ai choisi de
mettre en avant de deux femmes à voir
awa camara et maymou là bas qui sont les
fondatrices des crédits inclusive
l'abeille et le papillon
voilà sont des crèches qui permettent
notamment des microcrèches s'est déguisé
des détails l état ils sont un peu plus
petit que les crèches traditionnelles et
ses crèches en fait elles permettent de
mélanger des enfants qui ont des
handicaps notamment avec des enfants
dits valides
du coup voilà ça permet une vraie
l'inclusion et puis elles ont lancé un
nouveau à nouveau service également hors
les murs puisqu'elle propose de faire un
petit peu la même chose mais directement
dans des familles qui rencontrent des
difficultés difficultés qui ont été en
plus augmenter avec le co vider les
voilà les papas les mamans savent de
quoi on parle avec les difficultés à
faire garder des enfants
surtout quand voilà il ya des cas qui
sont destinés dans les écoles par
exemple
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je voulais
les mettre en avant et mettre en avant
cette belle initiative
ça fait déjà une bonne dizaine d'années
qu'elle se bat pour pour l'inclusion et
voilà ça s'appelle donc hors les murs a
été lancée voilà ce service de garde
assez original effectivement vous l'avez
compris
alexandre à présent pour les nouvelles
et 7,8 actu oui donc moi j'ai choisi de
mettre en avant jeunesse de la lande
donc c'est un jeune agriculteur de magny
les hameaux qui a repris la ferme
familiale il ya moins de deux ans la en
janvier 2019
donc c'était une ferme qui est détenu
par sa famille depuis je crois sans que
génération est en fait depuis qu'il est
arrivé à la tête de la ferme familiale
qui fait tout pour
pour développer son activité ça a
commencé cet été avec la création d'un
labyrinthe de maïs situé juste à côté de
la ferme sur un champ de maïs de deux
hectares qu'elle ait beaucoup de succès
cet été auprès des enfants
ça a continué avec l'installation de
plusieurs ânes deux ânes froid de la
neige
dans son champ ou séparer les enfants
viennent leur se promener voir les
animaux et ça continue la portée est
rentré fin septembre avec la création
d'une épicerie de produits cours qui
s'appelle le garde-manger et dans lequel
on retrouve de nombreux produits issus
des yvelines donc il va y avoir du
fromage de saint rémy les chevreuse il
va voir la mozzarella d'auffargis la
bière de coignières du pain du vin et je
trouve ça bien qu'un jeune un jeune
agriculteur
on dit que c'est une profession en
difficulté mais nous voir car jack comme
ça ils motivait multiplie les
initiatives pour développer son activité
je trouve ça bien
pendant que vous vous présentiez c'est
ce jeune agriculteur quelques images du
garde-manger justement vous allez aussi
lui rendre une petite visite et on
envoie quelques images voilà pour vos
personnalités à chacun grégory du côté
de tv 78 il ya une personnalité qui
n'est pas forcément yvelinoise mais en
tout cas qui est passé par les yvelines
que nous voulions aussi mettre en avant
c'est l'un des sujets que nous avons
traité depuis ce mois de septembre
oui puisque une affaire de viol présumé
qui a fait la une aussi dans les
yvelines alors il s'agit de julie son
nom a bien sûr été modifié puisque elle
était mineure au moment des faits elle
est la victime d'un viol présumé en 2009
trois pompiers avaient d'ailleurs été
mise en examen pour ces faits mais en
juillet 2019 le juge a finalement
requalifié en atteintes sexuelles alors
le 24 septembre dernier une audience
était prévue à la cour d'appel de
versailles pour faire annuler cette
décision une soixantaine de personnes
étaient venues en soutien à julie devant
la cour d'appel
à l'appel de plusieurs collectifs
féministes on peut citer nous toutes les
femen également osez le féminisme
il était aussi elles étaient venus ces
féministes soutenir aussi corinne qui
est la mère de la victime c'est elle que
nous avons choisi de mettre en avant
ecoutez-la ecoutez-le à l'issue de
l'audience elle a été interrogée par
eléonore sinoquet on est épuisés parce
qu'on est restés dehors c'était un peu
frustrant mais j'ai confiance dans nos
avocats nantes lui nous ont dit
e
j'ai un espoir parce que
toutes les femmes la juge est nouvelle
sur sur versailles
j'espère que enfin le dossier va être du
pour ce qu'il est et non pas
parce que ce sont des pompiers parce que
touchant des militaires voilà
juste il doit être en plus agile et le
verdict de la cour d'appel est attendu
pour le 12 novembre
nous passons à la dernière séquence de
cette émission bientôt à la une comme
chaque mois nous passons aux sujets qui
seront bientôt traiter par vos
différents médias locaux donc dans les
prochains jours alexandre ont commencé
avec vous bientôt à la une on va parler
d'une passerelle pascal de la discorde
peut-être c'est un sujet qui dure depuis
des années
c'est là pascal qui relie la galerie
marchande d'auchan à plaisir ou nouveau
centre commercial
mon grand plaisir et en fait cette
passerelle est fermé depuis des mois
pour des raisons de sécurité et ça pose
des gros problèmes
le propriétaire privé traînent des pieds
pour faire les travaux et du coup la
semaine dernière la commission de
sécurité est passée et a donné un nouvel
avis défavorable à l'ouverture de cette
passerelle qui reste donc fermée ce qui
a le don de mettre en colère donc les
commerçants de la galerie qui peuvent
pas profiter de ce flux de passants et
qui ont lancé une pétition et ça met en
colère aussi
la maire de la commune donc comme colas
berger ou qui a mis en demeure le
propriétaire privé n'a par sa parcelle
d'à de la passerelle d'effectuer les
travaux dans les deux mois et s'est pas
fait dans les deux mois donc d'ici le 30
novembre
la ville envisage de mener une action en
justice
passerelle donc qui ne permet pas la
fluidification de la circulation entre
les clients et qui forcément rajoute un
peu plus à la circulation qui est
globale des véhicules dehors qui est
assez problématique sur secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines
parce que du coup les gens passent par
un petit rond point qu'ils se trouvent
où qu'ils se trouvent deux ors et déjà
d'un c'est un peu dangereux déjà pour
les familles de devoir a traversé sur un
rond point et en plus effectivement ça
permet pas la finition là la circulation
puisque les voitures sont obligés de
s'arrêter sur le rond point concret de
la circulation les unes des nouvelles on
voit la photo de la passerelle donc les
travaux mise en demeure vous l'avez
entendu et le sujet complet sera à
découvrir dans les nouvelles justement
aux nouvelles dont on va voir les unes
une pour les différentes éditions celle
de versailles et puis celle de
rambouillet ensuite elle se sera donc en
kiosque disponible à partir de mercredi
comme chaque semaine et puis également
les articles à retrouver sur le 7-8
actus.fr nouradine à présent plusieurs
sujets que vous allez traiter sur votre
antenne sur marmite sur le 88 4
oui effectivement on va parler de la
fête de la science à saint quentin en
yvelines avec un village qui a lieu la
semaine on va également parlé avec l'ufc
que choisir d'obésité infantile avec les
publicités qui cible notamment les
enfants avec des produits super super
bon pour les ponts pour nos petits
enfants
on va également parlé de la pêche
durable
toujours avec le fc et puis du rail est
un terreau square également qu'a eu lieu
la semaine dernière
du côté de trappes voilà ça c'est pour
les sujets qui équivaut qu'ils vont être
développées wilfrid c'est très bien je
vois ça mais vous aviez le temps mais
vous avez fait courser très bien c'est
qu'on s'y grégory mallet ce que je peux
en profiter alors à 10 secondes
oui parce que les on peut poser la
question si l'émission vous réserve
votre bourse et à voir avec l'émission
mais sait c'est que du bonheur c'est une
association qui propose notamment parce
que vous savez on en plein qu'ovide la
situation dans les hôpitaux et est
encore pire que celle qu'on l'a connue
nous en confinement puisque les petits
les petites qui sont malades là bas à
bas ne peuvent pas avoir beaucoup de
visites alors nous ça fait plus de dix
ans qu'on propose des d'intervenir en
faisant des petites animations
voilà cette association a été lancé
notamment par l'épousé d'omar sy et puis
voilà donc n'hésitez pas c'est que du
bonheur avec un ke c'est que du bonheur
pour les faire pourrait faire des dons
auraient pu notamment voir ce qu'on fait
voilà merci wilfried merci plusieurs
très beaux tee shirt aussi très juste
très joli t-shirt mais je vous disais
avant l'émission tenez vous bien droit
qu'on puisse bien voir le logo parce que
les ans autre sujet qui sera abordé sur
notre antenne on va parler d'octobre
rose comme chaque année c'est le mois de
sensibilisation au cancer du sein le
cancer du sein qui est la première cause
de mortalité chez les femmes par cancer
ça concerne douze mille femmes chaque
année 1 qui décèdent de de cette cause
avec voilà un objectif chaque année
c'est de sensibiliser à la au dépistage
puisque le dépistage on sait que c'est
une clé importante dans ce cancer on
sait que dans neuf cas sur dix si le
dépistage est fait de manière précoce
les cancers peuvent guérir on sait aussi
que dans le même temps les femmes de 50
à 64 74 ans seulement 50% de ces femmes
effectuent aujourd'hui un dépistage
alors on a décidé d'en parler au cours
d'une édition cette semaine on recevra
le président de la ligue contre le
cancer des yvelines maurice brun on ira
également faire un reportage au crd
c'est alors le crtc c'est le centre et
de dépistage régional des cancers qui
est basée dans les yvelines aux chaînés
rocancourt qui a une mission
d'information d'orientation des femmes
aussi vers les structures agréées pour
les dépistages elle a aussi un rôle de
deuxième avis de deuxième lecture une
fois que ces dépistages sont effectuées
et plus et puis aussi un petit clin
d'oeil parce que chaque année il ya des
associations qui se mobilisent pour
cette lutte contre le cancer du sein et
cette année l'association pluriel
organise samedi samedi 10 octobre une
marche solidaire ce sera aux berges
envie de l'association appelle voilà à
chausser ses baskets pour venir marcher
auprès des bénévoles de cette
association et les fonds seront reversés
à la ligue contre le cancer et ce sujet
sera à découvrir dans le journal donc
soit en direct vous le savez à 18h du
lundi au jeudi rediffusion aussi à 19h
22h30 et puis il ya bien sûr les replays
j'en profite pour vous faire une
publicité auto promo et cette
application sur tv 78 sur les différents
smartphones et tablettes pour consulter
tous nos sujets et revoir le journal
présenté par vous grégory avant de juste
de terminer de dire au revoir aux
auditeurs téléspectateurs un mot
alexandre et puis nouradine sur le
contexte actuel on en a parlé lors des
précédentes éditions avant les vacances
mais sur la façon de travailler pour
vous c'est toujours un peu un peu
compliqué novo rédaction alexandre avec
la situation que vivent nos rangs
globalement sarabia repris on a moins de
l'inauguration moins d'événements le
week-end mais on fonctionne différemment
non globalement ça va plutôt de ce côté
là on vient avec aussi du côté de
marmites
oui tout à fait après c'est vrai que
nous depuis mais ça a commencé avec le
confinement on a multiplié les
interventions par téléphone qu on
faisait beaucoup moins avant donc c'est
vrai que c'est
renée changement principal mais bon on a
repris comme le travail sur le terrain
ce qui est le plus important
il ya encore des bénévoles d où les
bénévoles viennent travailler un
protocole sanitaire qui a été mise en
place
la marmite fm voilà c'est un peu
compliqué c'est un peu contraignant mais
voilà presque trentaine de bénévoles
peuvent continuer à faire leur émission
ils ont repris depuis sous ou vont
reprendre entre septembre et puis
jusqu'à la fin octobre tout le monde au
prix normal sociale vis aussi grâce au
travail de ses bénévoles bien souvent
vous vous êtes là pour relayer
l'actualité ils sont là aussi pour faire
vivre
l'antenne avec leurs différentes
émissions merci à tous les deux
alexandre nouradine d'avoir été présent
pour ce club de la presse merci
également à grégory c'est la fin de ce
numéro se retrouve le mois prochain et
si on peut juste refaire un plan sur
nouradine qui nous montrent fièrement
son tee shirt merci
et oh merci à bientôt
[Musique]